[Applauso]
[Musica]
avete mai avuto la sensazione che il
tempo scorra tra le dita come dei
granelli di sabbia che scendono dall
altro bene questo è il tempo che viviamo
è il tempo del tempo veloce le settimane
durano un giorno i giorni solo qualche
ora le ore pochi minuti le nostre
giornate
corrono mentre noi incontriamo persone
rispondiamo alle mail mandiamo messaggi
which at work shop e poi arriviamo alla
sera con quella sensazione di aver
prodotto soprattutto rumore movimento ma
non spostamento come una vecchia
automobile impantanata il motore sale di
giri il fumo degli scarichi corrompe
l'aria ma nulla si muove perché nel
tempo del tempo veloce non conta quante
cose facciamo in un giorno non conta
quanto tempo impieghiamo nel fare le
cose
tutto si confonde nella sera per vivere
nel tempo del tempo veloce è necessario
sviluppare un'abilità diverso che non
sta nel fare ma in una dimensione
alternativa è necessario trasformare il
tempo del tempo veloce nel tempo del
pensiero veloce e il pensiero veloce è
innanzitutto talento talento
innanzitutto di sapere dove siamo e dove
vogliamo andare
come enzo ferrari come ferruccio
lamborghini come i fratelli maserati
come la famiglia ducati come giampaolo
dallara che hanno creato valore sul
territorio in cui sono cresciuti ma come
alejandro de tomaso come ora sia pagani
che hanno trovato il paese che cercavano
e come quei ragazzi
che si spostano alla ricerca del loro
posto
dall'italia dall'europa dal mondo
spinti dalla passione e dal talento
il talento è di tutti
il talento del pensiero veloce non è di
pochi ma va educato ed allenato e per
educare questa capacità è necessario
generare conoscenza a partire dalla
conoscenza piuttosto che spostarla da
una parte all'altra
e necessario connettere le idee più che
essere connessi e necessario trattenere
per sé la consapevolezza di un piccolo
sapere più che mostrare una grande
dottrina affrontare la complessità dei
problemi più che ridurre tutto a
semplicistiche soluzioni per generare
conoscenza a partire dalla conoscenza
produrre idee bisogna raccogliere dati
elaborarli impiegare sensori avanzati e
raffinate strategie di lavorazione
magari basate sulla intelligenza
artificiale
esattamente come fanno i più evoluti
sistemi di guida autonoma ma i nostri
sensori sono gli occhi le orecchie le
mani gli occhi per guardarci intorno per
vedere la connessione tra le cause per
determinare gli effetti che ne derivano
le orecchie per raccogliere le
informazioni e gli avvertimenti che
provengono dall'esterno opinioni diverse
da confrontare che ci dicono quanto
solidi sono i dati che noi abbiamo le
mani capaci di sentire lo stato fisico
degli oggetti di percepire il materiale
di cui sono fatti l'intelligenza la
nostra è tutta naturale per connettere
le idee bisogna mettere in relazione
idee visioni diverse del mondo
confrontarle analizzarle come in un
sistema che distribuisce l'intelligenza
pensiamo a quei veicoli che non hanno un
intelligenza a bordo ricevono le
informazioni dall'esterno attraverso dei
sistemi ad alta velocità
di comunicazione le loro prestazioni
sono tante più alte quanto si riduce il
tempo che passa da quando ricevono il
comando quando lo mettono in atto ma se
la comunicazione cessa il sistema smette
di funzionare nel tempo del pensiero
veloce non ci si può affermare bisogna
avere una visione originale che ci
proietta in avanti una visione capace di
guidare le scelte una visione capace di
creare gli spazi invece che limitarsi ad
occuparli qualcuno dice che si è intuito
che sia innato la mia esperienza mi dice
che è solo connessione delle diversità
la loro sintesi perché il pensiero sia
veloce occorre che i meccanismi alla sua
base diventino automatici e perché siano
automatici bisogna trattenere per sé la
consapevolezza di un piccolo sapere
pezzo per pezzo parte per parte la
consapevolezza di ciò che avviene
intorno a noi deve diventare talmente
profonda da rendere perfettamente
connaturata con noi stessi ciò che
avviene ed è quello che facciamo nella
nostra piccola area qui a modena dove
testiamo veicoli di nuova generazione
prima all'interno di un ambiente
virtuale
poi all'interno di uno spazio
controllato e infine lanciando i veicoli
all'interno del mondo reale per migliaia
di chilometri prima che siano pronti
luoghi dove poter procedere con
regolarità per accelerare gli effetti
della ricerca lavorando insieme insieme
all'università insieme alle istituzioni
insieme alle aziende del territorio
perché il tempo del pensiero veloce ci
chiama a lavorare insieme perché il
pensiero sia veloce
occorre che l'azione lo seguo nel giusto
tempo e nella nostra società così veloce
così veloce al cambiamento almeno quanto
la tecnologia che la pervade non ci sono
problemi semplici non ci sono soluzioni
banali
pensiamo ad esempio alla mobilità come
ci muoveremo fra dieci anni ci muoveremo
fra dieci anni per cento anni fino ad
oggi il modello di mobilità è stato
sempre lo stesso
sapevamo da dove venivamo e sapevamo
predire dove saremmo andati oggi non è
più così
la risposta a quello che accadrà però lo
sappiamo è insieme nell'economia che
impatta la nostra quotidianità nella
giurisprudenza che scrive le regole
nell'ingegneria che fornisce gli
strumenti nella filosofia e nella
psicologia che ci dicono come il nostro
stare insieme nella medicina che
condiziona la qualità della nostra vita
nessuno di questi punti da sola
sufficiente a darci una risposta
e allora come dice ripete spesso andrea
pontremoli che il presidente
dell'associazione muner motor vehicle
university of emilia romagna l'unico
modo per risolvere un problema non
risolvibile e affidarlo a chi non sa che
non c'è soluzione tommaso è un
giovanissimo e promettente inventore sa
che il problema della mobilità
sostenibile a un problema complesso ma
ha trovato la soluzione ha già pensato
al suo primo prototipo è bastato il
tempo di un disegno un pensare veloce
libero da vincoli indipendente sfrontato
e allora il nostro ruolo di educatori di
giovani di studenti di figli di noi
stessi è quello di creare i luoghi dove
il pensiero veloce
sii educato ed allenato luoghi che sono
le nostre case la scuola l'università
luoghi dove poter parlare insieme di
conoscenza di connessione di
consapevolezza di complessità luoghi
dove poter sviluppare quel pensiero
veloce libero da vincoli indipendente
sfrontato esattamente come il pensiero
di tommaso
[Applauso]
[Musica]